Hold onto your hats, true believers the Marvel
rumor mill has cranked out a doozy.
According to We Got This Covered, anonymous
sources close to Marvel Studios have claimed
that a fourth Captain America picture is in
development one which will star Anthony Mackie,
as it'll see Sam Wilson officially taking
on the mantle.
Of course, we should be perfectly clear on
one point: There has been absolutely no official
word whatsoever about the possibility of a
fourth Captain America movie despite the rumors.
This is one of those situations that begs
the question: Do we believe everything we
read online?
"The answer is: You don't."
Sam Wilson's struggle with the legacy and
shield passed on to him by Steve Rogers at
the conclusion of Avengers: Endgame is thought
to be a major focus of the upcoming Disney+
limited series Falcon and the Winter Soldier,
which you will note carries a reference to
Wilson's original superhero moniker right
there in its title.
While we don't have all of the details yet,
we do know that the character of John Walker,
AKA U.S. Agent who has taken on the title
of Captain America at times in the comics
will be featured in the series, portrayed
by Wyatt Russell.
Signs seem to point to some kind of struggle
over who will be the next to fill Rogers'
shoes, and this new report seems to indicate
that when the dust settles on Falcon and the
Winter Soldier, Wilson will have emerged as
the new, uncontested Captain America.
It all makes sense on paper but is it actually
how Wilson's journey will play out?
Nobody seems to know and if they do, they're
keeping it super hush-hush.
There have been a couple of conflicting comments
made by Mackie himself which suggest that
as far as Wilson taking on the mantle of Cap,
Marvel may still be weighing its options.
First, there was the comment the star made
to MTV News back in July indicating that,
yes, he'd already put on the Captain America
suit.
Mackie said:
"I just had my first fitting.
It looks really good… they came to my house,
I did a fitting in my house."
In August, however, the actor appeared to
walk back his remarks when MTV News followed
up on the previous interview.
He explained:
"I don't even know if the suit's in the show.
And it's funny because I didn't have a fitting
for the suit.
I just had my fitting and … Everybody was
like, 'Oh, you had a fitting of your suit!'
And I was like, I never said I had a fitting
for the suit.
Go back to the tape, I said I had my first
fitting."
Yes, that is indeed what he said right after
the interviewer expressed his excitement to
see him wear the Captain America suit someday
soon.
The only thing clear here is that Mackie was
fibbing during one of those two interviews,
but we'd be hard pressed to say which one.
Then, consider the remark that Mackie made
at the D23 expo, also in August, when asked
if Falcon and the Winter Soldier would deal
with Wilson's transition to his new role as
Captain America.
He stated flatly:
"No, I am the Falcon.
I will always be the Falcon.
The moniker will stay the same."
That… doesn't appear to leave a whole heck
of a lot of room for interpretation so it
could very well be that, despite the fact
that Rogers obviously intended for Wilson
to become the new Cap, Wilson himself may
have other ideas.
At any rate, Marvel's complete slate of releases
through 2022 has been announced, so if we
are going to get a fourth Captain America
flick, it wouldn't be until 2023 at the very
earliest.
Based on the information that we have available
at the moment, however, we're going to go
ahead and say that the veracity of this report
is questionable at best.
Of course, we'll be keeping both ears to the
ground for any additional information, and
we'll be sure to keep you informed.
But Marvel has been keeping a pretty tight
lid on plot details for its Phase 4 projects,
so it wouldn't surprise us if we were to get
no solid leads on the studio's plans for the
character of Captain America before Falcon
and the Winter Soldier premieres on Disney+
in the fall of 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.